hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with Chris Edwards
of the Cato Institute he's the director
of Tax Policy Studies there and chris
has just released the fiscal policy
report card on America's governors for
2010 Chris thanks for coming who are the
best governors and why well every two
years we score the nation's 50 governors
and we give them sort of school grades a
for the good guys down to F for the
really bad governors and this year we
gave a's to four governors joe Manchin
West Virginia Democrat mark Sanford of
South Carolina Republican tim Pawlenty
Republican of Minnesota and bobby Jindal
Republican of Louisiana okay let's talk
about Sanford first is what was so good
about him besides the fact he was too
busy getting his ass kicked by the press
and his wife to really do much in terms
of increasing legislation in taxes well
mark Sanford really has been a champion
of both limited taxation and limited
spending in South Carolina remarkably
he's been in office for eight years and
the budget this year in South Carolina
is basically exactly the same dollar
amount as it was back in 2003 so he's
limited spending by vetoing dozens and
dozens of expensive spending bills and
on the tax front he's pushed really hard
for income tax cuts and sales tax cuts
what about somebody like mansion in West
Virginia who's now going into the US
Senate well Joe Manchin is very
interesting and he said he's a Democrat
he's been in office also eight years
he's been a very frugal on the on the
spending side he's pushed to cut
spending many years he's been in office
but really his biggest a favorable
attribute it is his business tax cuts he
has eliminated the franchise tax in West
Virginia he's eliminated license fees on
businesses and he's cut the corporate
income tax in West Virginia so he really
understands that his state's got to be
competitive in the national and world
economy so what what makes for an
effective tax cut you've talked about
how they get phased in over time how
does that work and what makes for an
effective spending cut is it all done it
once or is that phased in over time well
state governments work substantially
differently than if
the federal government can run deficits
and lessly it seems so if you cut taxes
at the federal level it doesn't mean the
politicians have to cut spending because
they can run big deficits at the state
level virtually all the states they have
to balance their budgets every year
either by tradition or statute or their
constitutions so when you want to cut
taxes at the state level you will often
phase them in overtime so the revenue
loss is a little bit at a time and you
can shift down spending too so that you
keep the budget balanced on the spending
side you know there's a there's really
no nothing prevents a governor's from
cutting spending whenever they want and
of course the recent years there's been
lots of efforts in places like Colorado
and South Carolina to put camps on the
overall budget so that it doesn't grow
faster than inflation are those
effective generally or are they mostly
symbolic there's a lot of states have
these sort of budget constraints but
they don't work very well in most states
Colorado is famous tabor has it's been
the most effective you know the idea is
that you don't want the government
growing spending during boom times
faster than the population is growing
because of course as we see in places
like Colorado during boom years they
spend too much and then the bust comes
and then the government runs giant
deficits right and you actually you talk
about how between two thousand and two
thousand eight state and local spending
rose fifty five percent on average Oh
what did that go into do we have
anything to show for that at the state
level well really it expanded government
you know all over the place Medicaid of
course hasn't been growing explosively
at the state level a state local level
of Prisons really all kinds of different
spending in education of course what
about a like in you said in South
Carolina it's basically the same as it
was in 2003 the total sprite re South
Carolinians doing okay with that or are
they wearing you know pickle barrel's
for clothes and walking on their feet or
what I think what you're asking nick is
can we get by with less government of
course the answer it is absolutely less
I mean the interesting thing the last
few years is that most states have cut
their budgets at least their general
fund budgets I mean even the left Lee
Democrats in places like Maryland have
cut their budgets pretty substantially
because they're forced to because they
have to balance their budget every year
now you do talk about the amount of debt
that states are in I mean that's
exploded over the over this decade
what's going on with that if in fact
they're cutting spending well really an
interesting thing that's been happening
with state governments is you go back
and look in the 1990s total state and
local government debt United States was
essentially flat for the whole decade at
about a trillion dollars this decade
state and local debt has exploded it's
more than doubled its over 2 trillion
dollars now so more and more states they
used to only go to the debt markets to
fund their capital investments more and
more they're using debt to fund their
regular operating expenses you have said
that you had a couple of surprises in
this somebody like Tim Pawlenty who's
often brooded about as a leading
Republican presidential candidate in
2012 what was he doing in Minnesota and
why did that surprise you well Tim
Pawlenty I you know honest I didn't know
much about him before I wrote up this
report I knew he was a social
conservative but I didn't know whether
it was a fiscal conservative he's been
fantastic he's been in office for eight
years he's been a frugal on the spending
side and on tax cuts he's been great he
has a left-leaning legislature that
keeps sending him tax hike bills he
vetoes them over and over his vetoed
income tax hikes and gas tax hikes and
alcohol gas tax hikes so he's been
really great he's cut spending during
the recession and he's absolutely
refused to raise taxes we take it for
granted in the pro free market you know
universe world that if you cut spending
if you keep spending down if you keep
taxes down everything will be okay does
this report kind of link the pro-growth
or what we presume are pro-growth
policies among governor's to actual
economic growth in the in their states
how do we know beyond satisfying our
kind of Vidya logical constraints that
this is actually doing something good
for the people who live under a temple
NT or a mark Sanford well there's no
doubt that the 50 states compete against
each other for investment for people for
high-income people and there's a lot of
variables that go into attracting
businesses and a vest
and of course you know nice climate like
Florida and Arizona of course attract a
lot of retirees the you know a lot of
the sites you mean unbearably hot for
anybody under about six well since the
invention of by air conditioning of
course six or seven decades ago that
there's been a huge magnet drawing
American side with and so you know in
addition this other states of course
generally have lower taxes in the
northeastern states and that there's a
lot more right-to-work states in the
South in other words states that don't
have forced collective bargaining and
unionization so all these factors go
into drawing business investment and so
you can look at a place like West
Virginia and governor there Joe Manchin
he's cut taxes but he's done a lot of
other pro pro friend business friendly
policies as well and the West Virginia
economy has done very well how does the
stimulus dollars that have been poured
into state budgets over the past 18
months or and I guess we're a little bit
longer now how is that affecting the way
that their financing things over the
over the time that this report covers
well I I think federal aid to the states
which you know has soared in recent
decades really starting from my Lyndon
Johnson the 1960s it's a cancer on
American government because it reduces
the responsibility for state local
governments to tax and fund their own
programs they get these subsidies from
the federal government for things like
Medicaid and it encourages them to over
expand these programs this is a really
bad trend to increasingly fun state
governments from from the federal
taxpayers if if you can give governor's
or state legislatures one bit of advice
based on your findings in the fiscal
report card the fiscal policy report
card what is it well I think that the
number one policy that I would propose
to state governors to get their
economies moving to grow out of this
recession is to eliminate their state
corporate income taxes state corporate
income taxes are really the stupidest
tax in America they distort businesses
they scare away investment both domestic
and international investment and they
hardly raise any money anyway so states
don't need them and we
half a dozen states that don't have
corporate income taxes and their
economies do pretty well I want to thank
Chris Edwards director of tax policy at
the Cato Institute and the author of the
fiscal policy report on America's
governors for 2010 Chris thanks for
coming by
you
you